[Musica]
Da che mondo è mondo c'è uno spettro Che
angoscia l'essere umano e cioè che
qualcosa di più forte di lui prenderà il
potere lo comanderà all'inizio erano gli
dei ma adesso Sono principalmente le
macchine l'idea che ci siano queste
macchine efficientissime potentissime
bravissime che si mettono al posto
nostro fanno tutto e ci fanno fare tutto
quello che vogliono
ripeto non è una cosa che risale agli
ultimi anni dell'intelligenza
artificiale o a quella che si chiama
l'età della Tecnica Poi fra l'altro
l'età della Tecnica è una definizione
ben strana visto che l'età della Tecnica
incomincia con l'essere umano l'essere
umano è quell'animale che diversamente
da tutti gli altri animali e
sistematicamente collegato con un
apparato tecnologico bene
Ma cosa sarebbe questo
presa del potere da parte del della
macchina c'è il Golem il Golem a questa
costruzione
a Praga dove un rabbino costruisce con
rifacendo l'opera di Dio costruisce
questo automa che poi prende il potere
gli fa male Lo uccide o sta per
ucciderlo e Frankenstein è tutta tutta
questa ampia letteratura diciamo così ma
adesso non è più letteratura fantastica
La cosa bella che crediamo di essere in
una realtà secolarizzata invece non c'è
verso di leggere un giornale o di
guardare un telefilm in cui non si parli
del fatto che le macchine prenderanno il
potere oppure come dicono sempre Siamo
schiavi delle macchine il telefonino ci
fa fare tutto quello che vogliamo che
ancora ne idea della responsabilità
umana dal momento che In definitiva
se è stupido attribuire l'uccisione di
Cesare i pugnali e altrettanto stupido
attribuire le nostre azioni ai
telefonini però si dice non ho guardate
adesso questa intelligenza artificiale è
fortissima e onnipotente ed è per questo
che dobbiamo
obbedirla a puntino Non è mica in fondo
con un bastone con una Rivoltella con un
mulino a vento uno un po' Di iniziativa
c'era ma con l'intelligenza artificiale
non c'è niente da fare
superstizione pur è semplice
superstizione perché dentro a questa
superstizione ci sono due elementi uno
che è perfettamente vero e cioè le
macchine ci prenderanno il lavoro sono
fatte per quello perché a capa parità di
condizione una macchina è sempre meglio
di un umano per svolgere certi compiti
perché la macchina non muore la macchina
non ha diritti la macchina non si
lamenta la macchina non ha fame e la
macchina non si ribella e quindi sempre
meglio la macchina
però attenzione
Per quanto riguarda invece l'umano
tranquilli non sarà mai dominato dalla
macchina per un motivo banale perché per
volere il potere bisogna avere un
organismo il potere è qualcosa che nasce
dal timore nasce dal dover soddisfare
dei bisogni impellenti dal pensare che
qualcuno ci stia portando via qualcosa
che di cui potremmo approfittare noi dal
garantirci il controllo sulle altre
persone Allora
quando io vedo un consiglio di
dipartimento sono un filosofo e vedo il
consiglio di dipartimento di filosofia
sono tutte persone perbene bravissime
istruitissime eccetera però le dinamiche
sono grosso modo quelle che si possono
vedere in un branco di scimmie ma non
perché sia in scimmie per davvero ma
semplicemente perché sono organismi
quindi ci bambino desideri bisogni
voglia di dominanza eccetera mentre non
vedremo mai nulla di tutto questo fra le
macchine io non riesco ad immaginare una
situazione di Internet of Things in cui
c'è il tostapane che cerca di prendere
il potere rispetto al frigorifero sono
proprio cose che non si rappresentano
perché la macchina non ha bisogno la
macchina la timori la macchina non si
annoia e quando una macchina sente per
esempio che gli sta per mancare il
carburante o l'energia non è che vieni
smanio cerchi di rubare il carburante o
l'energia ad un'altra macchina
semplicemente si spegne perché sa che
poi si riaccenderà mentre un organismo
si dà molto da fare perché sa che una
volta che è spento Non si riaccende più
allora
se le cose stanno in questi termini è
assolutamente implausibile l'idea del
Golem e della macchina che prende il
potere e lo è tanto di meno in quanto
adesso la tecnica sofisticata
può sembrare strano ma invece è proprio
così nel senso che
un bastone è uno strumento tecnico molto
rudimentale ma che ha una certa
autonomia lo può usare anche una scimmia
per esempio e l'umano lo può usare per
tantissimi scopi già una catena di
montaggio
ha degli scopi molto limitati e quindi
ha bisogno che l'umano faccia certe cose
E se l'umano non fa certe cose non
funziona
la macchina delle macchine il web
l'intelligenza artificiale non ha più
bisogno dell'umano come parte della
macchina come un pezzo che aggiunge
qualcosa alla macchina ma in tutto e per
tutto dipendente dall'umano in quanto
umano dal momento che ha bisogno di
imparare Come funzionano gli umani per
poter limitare sapere come parlano gli
umani saperi di che cosa hanno bisogno
gli umani capire perché gli umani fanno
delle cose che sembrano irrazionali però
sono radicalmente umane un computer non
le farebbe mai quindi ha la macchina
Dipende in tutto e per tutto dell'umano
dall'umano bene
una volta che abbiamo scacciato lo
spettro del Golem ci resta un
interrogativo da chiederci Ma perché
diavolo c'è così tanti filosofi che ci
dicono che noi siamo schiavi della
Tecnica e che della Tecnica ci comanda
Ma io credo che questi filosofi abbiano
si siano ispirati tutti quanti a Martin
Heidegger questo filosofo che in una
famosa conferenza abrema nel
1949 ha detto che ormai Siamo schiavi
della Tecnica la tecnica ci comanda ci
fa fare tutto quello che vuole e via
Ormai dobbiamo rassegnarci a questa
imposizione
perché l'ha detto Boh non saprei dire
perché l'abbia detto Heidegger però sono
molto bene perché l'ha detto quello da
cui Heidegger ha copiato ed è Albert
spear il ministro degli armamenti del
terzo Reich che a Norimberga si è
dichiarato colpevole con questo
guadagnandosi l'indulgenza dei giudici
ma subito dopo ha detto sì sono
colpevole però la Germania era uno stato
così tecnicamente ordinato e organizzato
che la tecnica ci imponeva che cosa fare
e quindi eravamo tutti quanti schiavi
della Tecnica Allora io capisco
benissimo Per quale motivo qualcuno che
ha accusato di genocidio debba dar la
colpa alla tecnica ma noi che
normalmente non siamo accusati di
genocidio vogliamo prenderci le nostre
responsabilità invece che incorpare
sempre i telefonini e l'intelligenza
artificiale
[Applauso]